well put your conspiracy caps on folks
because Jeffrey Epstein was found
injured in prison in his prison cell
he's fine injured not much else is known
other than that he was found laying in
his in his cell marks around his neck
poor guy was he assaulted did he try to
kill himself did he fake a suicide
attempt and in hopes of being
transferred something like that we don't
know based on what little we know I tend
to suspect maybe a third option but but
who knows yet of course the wild
conspiracy theories start online maybe
the Clintons tried to off him because he
knows too much
maybe Trump tried to off him you know
maybe maybe it was aliens well I hate to
I hate to be the one to ruin all of
these cinematic plot lines but I think
of a powerful person is sending a hit
man to prison to kill you you aren't
going to end up with minor lacerations
around your neck I think that I mean
that's one ineffective assassin and so
it just doesn't I mean I don't really
know my experience with hiring prison
assassins is admittedly limited it's
really for me it's sort of a once in
awhile type of thing that I do that but
you know when you're what when the
window when the wife really nags you
about it says hey did you hire that
prison assassin yet I'll get her I said
I would I'll get around to it get off my
case you know that kind of thing
so I'm not an expert is the point here's
a general rule though that I think
people need to understand even if it is
kind of depressing of all the possible
explanations and this is a general
statement of all the possible
explanations the most boring one is
always right every time whatever the
situation is the most boring possible
explanation is going to be correct and I
think if you remember that life will
start to make a lot more sense to you
even if life is a little bit less
interesting when you start looking at it
that way that is that is going to be
most of the time correct all right I
want to begin with something that I
think is instructive our friend
Ilhan Omar
there's a video another video that from
from last year that has resurfaced
resurfaced as they say she was on
al-jazeera
and she was asked whether Islamophobia
can't be in in some sense justified
based on the fact that radical Muslims
kill so many people and so maybe people
are afraid for a reason given all this
terrorism and violence and she responded
by of course as she tends to do spewing
ignorant bigotry watch this a lot of
conservatives in particular would say
that the rise in Islamophobia is a
result a lot of hate but a fear a
legitimate fear they say of
quote/unquote jihadist terrorism whether
it's Fort Hood or San Bernardino or the
recent truck attack in New York what do
you say to them I would say our country
should be more fearful of white man
across our country because they are
actually causing most of the deaths
within this country we should be
profiling monitoring and and and
creating policies to fight the
radicalization of white men okay now she
could have said to that question I don't
expect her to say that
oh yeah well as llama phobia is totally
justified Muslims are just the worst man
I don't expect that answer okay she
could have said we shouldn't fear
anybody based on their race or ethnicity
we should judge people on a case-by-case
basis so on and so forth that's that's
the answer that a non bigoted would have
given instead she says no we should fear
the white man we should be fearful of
white men because white men are causing
most of the deaths in our country that's
what she said causing most of the deaths
in our country now it is not this this
woman now god help us is a lawmaker
she's also got to help us one of the
more influential voices in politics
today so when she says something like
that it's not splitting hairs or neither
or being pedantic to analyze that claim
that is a that's a startling claim and
it's a claim that
people believe you'd be amazed if you
try maybe you wouldn't be you have this
conversation as I have been online this
morning there are a lot of people who
think that's true who actually believe
that because they hear it from people
like Ilhan Omar they think oh yeah well
good white white men by far kill the
most people now when she says cause
causing most of the deaths I'm going to
assume now I will do her one favor I'm
gonna do her a favor and I'm going to
assume that she doesn't mean that
completely literally okay because the
leading causes of death are heart heart
disease car accidents respiratory
disease stroke cancer diabetes these are
the leading causes of death I assume she
is not suggesting that the white man is
engineering all of that although
honestly who knows I I mean I wouldn't
put it past her to make that claim but
I'm going to assume I'm going to be
generous and assume she didn't mean that
I'll assume that what she meant is that
white men are responsible for most of
the murders in this country causing most
of the death to cause death I assume she
means that in a sense of murdering
people and if that's what she means then
she's still wrong she is still
catastrophically insanely incredibly
wrong according to the Bureau of Justice
Statistics white people in general not
just men the people because women do
kill people too despite what you may
have heard and in fact we are in this
whole conversation we're just leaving
out the you know eight hundred and nine
hundred thousand babies who are killed
every year in this country if you were
to if you were to allow that into
evidence if that could be submitted into
evidence then in fact the leading
murderers in America would be women but
we're going we're gonna look at we're
gonna look at law enforcement statistics
for this so I you know I'm doing Ilhan
Omar a lot of favours here I'm ruling
that out I'm probably yet I'm trying I'm
trying to see her comments in the most
sensible light possible
so what do we find white people in
general commit 45 percent of all murders
according to the Bureau of Justice
Statistics black people commit 52
percent of all murders now this is
remarkable because white people are
seventy five percent of the population
black people are thirteen percent
seventy five percent of the population
commits 45 percent of the murders 13
percent commits 52 those are facts okay
white people are way way way way
underrepresented in the murder stats
again that's a simple fact and that's
all it is if we're gonna talk
specifically about terrorism that's not
what she said she said we should fear
the white man because they're they're
the ones killing most of the people and
when we look at that statistic again it
is proven utterly bogus no basis in
reality whatsoever let's look at
terrorism over look at specifically at
terrorism and if we take a global view
of the problem well let's just put it
this way according to the global
terrorism index far-right groups killed
so-called far-right groups kill and we
want to get into how they judge
far-right for instance you know any
anti-semitic anytime a white person
commits an anti-semitic hate crime which
we know does happen they're gonna call
that far-right which personally I think
we could quibble with that but I won't
for this so if they say they say
far-right groups killed 66 people across
the entire world between 2013 and 2017
according to the global terrorism index
66 people in four years 2013 2017
meanwhile
in 2017 alone just that year 18,000
total people were killed by terrorists
so you've got 66 people in four years
across the entire world killed by
right-wing terrorists but 18,000 were
killed total in just one year in 2017
who do you think is responsible for
almost all of that
I'll put it to you this way that same
index finds that nine of the ten worst
countries for terrorism
nine of the ten countries most plagued
by terrorism are majority Muslim
countries with one outlier number ten
being India and India is like fifteen
percent Muslim so again those are the
facts in order to make white men the
greatest danger you have to really do
some serious special pleading and you do
hear this from people like I said I've
been hearing it this morning that white
men are the biggest dangers right-wing
groups are more dangerous in America
than Islamic terrorists or any other
terrorist in in order to now you can
make any statistic work if you if you
whittle down the parameters in a really
specific way in order to make it work
that's called special pleading and if
you do that then sure you can make that
happen so so how do how do people do
that how do they reach the conclusion if
you if you wanted to claim that
right-wing terror groups white people in
other words are the deadliest the most
dangerous how are you gonna do that well
a report from the Government
Accountability Office in 2017 found that
right-wing terror groups were
responsible for more deaths than Islamic
groups and and in fact when you when you
hear this claim it's most of the time if
they well most the time they're not
going to cite it they're not gonna give
you a citation at all whoever's making
the claim you ask for a citation they
won't have one but if they do have one
and they provide it to you probably it's
going to be this or something based on
this well how do they arrive at that
conclusion I'll quote now from their
report says of the eighty-five violent
extremist incidents that resulted in
death since September 12 2001 far-right
politics violent extremist groups were
responsible for sixty two of the deaths
73 percent total while radical Islamist
violent extremist groups were
responsible for 23 that's 27 percent the
total number of fatalities is 106 for
far-right vile extremists and 119 for
radical Islamist violent extremists over
the approximately 15 year period however
52 percent of the deaths attributable to
radical Islamist violent extremists
occurred in a single event an attack on
pulse nightclub in Orlando Florida in
2016
okay hmm since September 12 2001 why
such a specific date I mean why not
since the turn of the millennium why not
in the past 20 years or past 30 I mean
it says there approximately 15 year
period well why not a 15 year period
from when this study was done this this
study counted 2001 to 2016 said
approximately 50 why not fit why not
just make it 15 2001 to 2016 well we
know why of course because the deadliest
attack on American soil in history
happened on September 11th and that was
brought to us courtesy of Muslims so in
other words if you don't count the
deadliest attack on American soil ever
in history which happened in this
century it's not ancient history now if
it happened 200 years ago and you
weren't counting it then then fine ok so
if you were doing 2001 to 2015 or 2016
and the the worst attack in history was
done by Muslims you know in 1907 or
something then I think that's fair but
when you are specifically making the
parameters to start the day after that
attack and to go and again to go 15
years before it it's as I said I mean
this is the definition of special
pleading you're you know what conclusion
you want and so you're engineering it to
get that conclusion it's just a
worthless statistic if we include the
deadliest attack in American history
which is recent history still recent
then you find that deaths by Muslim
terrorists way outnumber I mean then
it's then it's over 3,000 verse what do
they say 106 well since this report
there have been there been other there
been other masks as
events so you know well let's say one
one twenty or something verse over three
thousand I mean it's it's just it's not
even close
and the really absurd thing is that even
in this report they're also now they
know they can't do it but they also say
well also keep in mind that that half of
the deaths by Muslims was with just that
one event so what they really want to do
is they want you to exclude that one too
that's what that's kind of what their
sayings like well you know that one so
let's exclude that that's an outlier
let's exclude 9/11 and then and then
it's like good Muslims haven't killed
anybody
practically I mean if you exclude all of
the incidents of them killing people
they haven't killed anybody it's just
you see what has to be done to make with
the white man the biggest threat you see
how ludicrously specific and tailor-made
the parameters have to be in order to
get to that conclusion now this is
instructive and and here's really the
point to me is that what you see here
from Ilhan Omar this is bigotry okay
what Omar is saying is bigotry and I
know you could say well he said the
white men kill the most people and
you're saying that's better but you just
said that black people are responsible
52% of murders even though the 13
percent spot population isn't that
bigoted on your part to bring that up no
it's not and I'll tell you the
difference because what I said is true
okay so a fact can never be racist I
want to say that again
a fact can never be racist because it's
a fact now you could use a fact to come
to a racist conclusion that's true it's
very possible for a racist person to
take facts and then arrive at racist
conclusions absolutely but to simply
cite a fact especially in in in
contradiction of a of an of a falsehood
in order to correct the falsity that's
not racist it just is it that's just is
the fact I'm not I'm not writing at any
conclusion I'm
saying anything beyond this is these are
the facts that's it here you go
arrived at your own conclusions
Ilhan Omar on the other hand is is
saying something that is untrue about a
racial group other than her own in order
to stoke fear and suspicion of that
group that is classic bigotry that
that's that's that is dictionary
textbook dictionary right a bigotry
right there yeah I just said its text
its dictionary textbook dictionary I can
barely even speak it's so bigoted it's
it's it's rendered me almost speechless
but it really is that's that's just
textbook stuff right there you are
you're this is fear-mongering you're
making up these untrue statements about
another racial group in order to fear
monger and she was explicit with the two
she said we should fear them so let's
imagine for a moment that a right-wing
white politician were to say hey you
know black people they they they've
killed 98 percent of the people 98
percent of murders in this country from
black people and so we should fear them
now if a white politician were to say
that first of all they'd be run out of
office in 30 seconds you'd never see or
hear from them ever again on a public
stage that would be it and that would be
bigoted because you are explicitly
trying to stoke fear against another
racial group and you're doing it with
falsehoods in fact even if a white
politician were to stick with the facts
and we're to say look black people
commit 52 percent of murders even though
the 13% of the population therefore we
should fear them so you started with a
fact but you arrived at a racist
conclusion you're stoking fear you're
saying we should fear an entire race
based on this fact that would be racist
- even though it's based in effect but
when you combine the falsehood with the
fear-mongering I mean good lord good
Lord you just you can't get more racist
than that all right speaking of them try
to pull something up as we are speaking
of false claims want to look at another
one today an article on the website big
think which is ironically named and
we'll see why in a minute has been
making the rounds today let me read a
little bit of this from the articles is
the worst countries in the world to be a
woman places torn apart by war or
society stifled by centuries of male
part patriarchy a recent survey by the
Thomas the Thomson Reuters foundation
show so which category does the United
States fall into because the you the
us-made 10th place the oh I'm sorry this
article is so poorly written I'm having
trouble reading it coherently because
the us-made 10th place the only western
country on the list conducted online by
phone and in person between March 26 and
May 24th the survey polled 548 experts
on women's issues spread evenly across
Europe the Americas Asia and the Pacific
those surveys included academics and
policymakers health care staff and NGO
workers aid and development
professionals and social commentators
social commentator they're experts they
were asked which five of the UN's 193
member states but what does it even mean
at least averman experts on women's
issues what is what does that even mean
Allie how are you you're an expert on
women what what what can I be an expert
on men so if you want to know about
men's issues can you call me up I'm a
social commentator and I'm a man so that
makes me an expert
we're asked which five of the UN's 193
member states they thought were the most
dangerous for women in six areas health
care economic resources culture cultural
or traditional practices sexual violence
and harassment non-sexual violence and
human trafficking
so okay I'm just gonna I'll stop reading
from the article which as I said is
bismallah written this is from Big Think
worst countries to be a woman most
dangerous countries for women let's look
then at the top ten that this that these
experts give us number one India
number two Afghanistan number three
Syria number four Somalia number five
Saudi Arabia number six Pakistan number
seven Democratic Republic of Congo
number eight Yemen number nine Nigeria
number ten the United States one of
these does not belong let's add that so
that's a fun game to play which of these
which of these is not like the other the
US then according to act according to
experts is more dangerous for women than
Iran Iraq North Korea China Ethiopia
Egypt Libya Sudan in fact in our
hemisphere we are the worst place for
women according to experts worse than
Mexico El Salvador Guatemala Brazil
Nicaragua were worse than all those
places which is weird because all of
those places are places where women are
fleeing to come here turns out we're
worse you know it turns out we're doing
them a favor when we stand at the border
we got then if we were to ever build a
wall which looks like it's gonna happen
if we have we built a big wall that
Donald Trump promised and hasn't
delivered and we stood there we said no
turnaround we'd be doing them a favor
it's so much worse here especially if
you're a woman now this is obviously
completely ridiculous with no basis in
reality there's a reason why they're
they're doing this study by polling
so-called experts rather than looking at
the statistics you could look at the
stats and see murder rate rates of
sexual assault rape poverty rate rates
of you know
people being in prison without trial I
mean
violence against women domestically but
you could these things are these are all
statistics and in some of these
countries it's good because some of
these countries are just hell holes it's
gonna be harder to get statistics from
but but you you couldn't you could do it
that way but they're not doing it that
way instead they're just gonna they're
gonna call up 538 random women and say
hey what do you think about this well
let's give us your opinion and we'll
we'll make a list so how could anyone
actually make this claim well I think
for one what you see here is a very
weird kind of self-centeredness I
guarantee that the experts in America
the so-called experts they were the ones
probably saying that America is so bad
because they just assumed that their own
experience their own trials their own
tribulations however petty must be the
worst possible thing when you hear
Americans talk about America as if it's
the most dangerous and sexist and
bigoted and homophobic place on earth
what you're hearing in part is
narcissism they're saying that because
they live here and so they just assume
it has to be whatever they're going
through it's got to be it's got to be
the worst or among the worst things that
anyone could go through so a woman a
feminist in America she if you're a
feminist in America living in a you know
living in an urban center or whatever
and you're going about your day what
what's the sort of everyday incidents of
sexism and and and what's the kind of
persecution and oppression that you
could expect to experience on an
everyday basis cuz you know you could
you wake up in the house you own because
you're allowed to own property in
America which isn't the case in a lot of
other countries especially in the Middle
East you go to your job because you're
allowed to have a job in America not the
case in many other countries
also we have an economy that allows
pretty much anyone to get a job if you
really want one which is not the case in
many other countries including south of
the border which is why they're coming
here you have a nice breakfast which in
many countries there's not gonna be a
lot to eat Venezuela being one of them
you leave your house you go to your job
you walk down the street you don't have
to really worry you get on the subway
okay well now that you're on the subway
now we've got our first density because
there might be manspreading
on the subway right you get on the
subway there might be you want to sit
down there might be a guy is spreading
his legs a little bit too much and
increment encroaching on your space a
little bit
now there's also gonna be women who take
up entire seats with their purses well
that's okay you know you're allowed now
a guy who needs to spread legs will but
because of because of the equipment that
men carry around that's not okay but a
woman takes up an entire seat with her
purse with her stuff that she loves over
that's fine anyway
but that's so there's oppression right
there that's your first incident it's
it's 9:30 in the morning
you've already you've already been
oppressed okay then you get off your
subway you walk toward you're fine you
get to work and then maybe a male
coworker talks to you and maybe he's a
little bit too friendly maybe he come
maybe he complements you if you could a
worst case scenario maybe cut maybe he
can't maybe even compliments what you're
wearing says you look nice today
let me asked you how you how your
weekend would you know I mean in a
nightmare scenario nightmare maybe he
even say asks what you're doing later
and sees if you want to hang out god
forbid god forbid okay there's your
an incident of oppression and then you
go about your day you're working you go
home I mean so so we I don't know we
maybe we've got two incidents there
persecution for women on an everyday
basis but from from the perspective of a
feminist in America that has to be the
that has to be among the worst of course
there are countries where you could
essentially as a woman be legally raped
there are countries where you're not
allowed to drive there are countries
where you you can't if you walk down the
street with anything more than your face
showing you could be stoned to death or
beaten there are countries where if
you're raped you could be killed for it
but no the man spreading on the subway
that's that's just as bad it's gotta be
you know why because it happened to me I
think and then the other problem that we
have is and this is of course is related
but the other problem is people in this
country just having no understanding of
no appreciation of the state of things
in other parts of the world and that's
become a big problem the people in this
country are so privileged and so
comfortable and just we're so fat and
happy and and maybe not happy but fat
and satiated and comfortable living in
luxury we just we have no idea what it's
like in other parts of the world and
certainly throughout history so we
don't appreciate the fact that in this
country you know we have problems in
this country that's true but welcomes to
racism sexism poverty all those things
it's pretty much as good in this country
as it's ever been anywhere could still
be better we could still work on making
it better but it says it's as good as
it's ever been
anywhere but we have no appreciation for
that and thus and thus we have we have
no gratitude either and that's I think a
big part of the problem
all right um let's see here I think
we'll move on to emails Matt Walsh show
at gmail.com Matt Walsh show at
gmail.com this is from Bridget says hi
Matt I just want to share a word I found
that you were describing in your podcast
you were talking about the feeling of
recognizing that everyone around you has
their own life that is as important as
central as your as yours is to you the
word for that is sonder the definition
is the realization that each random
passerby is living a life as vivid and
complex as your own what a humbling
feeling it's pretty cool that enough
people have encountered that emotion
that there's a word to describe it it
sort of feels like a proof of shared
humanity to me anyways when I found that
word I thought it was awesome and I just
want to share with you yeah we were
talking yesterday on the show about I
was having my I was essentially like a
like a stones 16 year old in his friends
basement trying to get philosophical hey
man have you ever thought about how like
everybody is a is a person man I was
having that moment free of drugs though
I should mention I didn't know there was
a word for it Saunders is that so where
does that where is that in the
dictionary that's it's interesting that
there's actually a word for that for
that experience and that just shows I
guess what we're talking about that that
you know you had you have these
experiences these internal experiences
you have this internal life and you
think you sort of think you're alone
with it and then you recognize that all
these thoughts that you think we're
unique where other people have
experienced the same thing which i think
is is comforting if you look at it the
right way this is from Nick said
yesterday someone sent me the following
quote in enjoy life to the fullest it
has an expiration date
this sang obviously echoes many other
many others with a similar sentiment
Yolo comes to mind you only live once
kids used to say that my question for
you is from a Christian worldview do you
think this is a good this is good or bad
advice perhaps the answer hinges on what
constitutes a living life to the fullest
take it to its logical conclusion the
mindset could be used to justify in
moral actions like infidelity theft or
shaving off a perfectly healthy beard on
the other hand recognition of one's own
mortality and finding joy life seemed
perfectly in keeping with the Christian
worldview I'm only asking you to wax
philosophical consider yourself lucky
this isn't Candida yeah I think if we
keep the proper perspective on it
there's truth to it it's a cliche
there's when it comes down to there's
really no reason to say it for the
simple reason that it's a cliche there's
really no reason to say a cliche that's
a cliché for a reason we all know it
already we would salt it's in our head
we've encountered it before so there's
no reason to say it for that reason but
yeah I think that leaving the cliched
nature of it aside there is truth to the
to the fact that you should enjoy your
life you only get it once now there is
we believe obviously as Christians that
there's a life beyond this one but that
doesn't make this life worthless and I
do think that's an important point and
sometimes the way Christians sometimes
can tend to talk about it it's as if
they think that this life doesn't mean
anything well of course it means
something God gave us this life to live
and so and that's why when someone is
killed it's it is a tragedy that's why
if you lose a loved one
you mourn even if you know that they
hopefully went on to a better place that
there is a life beyond this but you
still mourn because you recognize that
something has been lost one of my
favorite CS Lewis books is a grief
observed and that's the book that he
wrote after his wife died one of his one
of his last book during towards the end
of his life he wrote this book and and I
believe the book originally was not he
didn't intend to publish it he was just
sort of his oh he was writing a journal
and
expressing kind of working through his
trauma that he was feeling after his
wife died of I believe it was cancer and
this is then at the beginning it's a
very short book but at the beginning of
the book he's angry at God he seems
almost on the verge of giving up on
faith by the end he he doesn't spoiler
alert but this is one thing that he
talked about there's a great quote in
there and then I'm gonna have to
paraphrase but he says that you know Eve
even though he knows that his wife has
gone on to the next life he also knows
that this world this physical world is
is completely devoid of her and that if
he were to search the entire universe
every crack and crevice of the universe
he would not find her anywhere she is
she is in a very real sense gone and
that is that's that's not an illusion or
something she really is gone for all
intents and purposes from this world and
that is a sad thing so the point is that
that life is meaningful and and so I
don't think there's anything wrong with
saying live it to the fullest but if by
that you mean throw morality throw
discipline throw self-control to the
side because when you die you're just
gonna decay and fade into nothingness
and there's nothing beyond it if that's
what you mean then then obviously
there's a problem this is from Josh this
hello.mat short version of my question
would you ever leave Twitter even though
I assume doing so would adversely affect
your career as a media personality
what would Twitter need to do to make
you leave I've gotten this question
several times as we talked I think it
was yesterday or two days ago we talked
about what I think is the most egregious
thing Twitter has done and they've done
a lot of egregious things in terms of
their bias against conservatives or
their bias in favor of far-left
ideology the most egregious thing is the
case with this man who's trying to sue
women in Canada to get his genitals
waxed and he has been harassing women
online and the women who've stood up to
him one in particular who he harassed
and mocked in a sexually degrading way
she stood up to him
and responded in kind and was perfectly
justified to it she was banned from
Twitter permanently and he's still there
even though this guy is a creep and and
a predator just a monster in many ways
with from the way that he treats women
and and other things as well after we
talked about that I had a lot of emails
like this people saying well okay if you
think Twitter so bad why don't you sign
off why don't you leave on your boycott
it and and I understand that question
and that is something that I struggle
with I think the easy cop-out answer is
that for me with my job I really I have
to be on it I can't leave it at least
not by my own choice
that's the cop-out answer but even even
if I didn't have sort of a professional
obligation to be on Twitter and to be on
social media given my job I don't know
if I would leave it because if I can use
the platform if I'm able to use the
platform to undermine Twitter's own
ideological agenda if I can use this
platform to get the truth out there to
get conservative ideas out there then
why wouldn't I use it I'll use it until
I can't anymore until they take it from
me so what I've decided
and I've long ago decided this with
Twitter with Facebook too but especially
with Twitter that as long as I have this
platform and I can use it just to speak
the truth I'm going to do that I'm not
gonna censor myself at all so that is my
personal pledge I'm not gonna now if
you're if you're if you're on Twitter
you're on these social media sites and
you're censoring yourself in order to
maintain that platform well then there's
really no point okay then you might have
been the best thing in that case would
be just to leave but I'm not gonna
censor myself at all and I'll just
so I don't know maybe it's kind of a
kamikaze mission I'm just gonna continue
using it not censor myself in the least
bit and if they eventually come along
and ban me than they do but if they
don't I'm gonna continue using it to
undermine their own ideological agenda
that's that's the way that I that I look
at it you know even when we've been
talking about this issue with this guy
in Canada and what I want when I'm when
I'm using Twitter you know I'm as I said
I'm gonna so I'm gonna speak the truth
I'm not I'm not gonna say something
that's not true just to follow the rules
of a social media site so for instance
I'm gonna refer to this man as a man
even if Twitter says well you're not
allowed to do that that's misgendering
well I'm not gonna lie for Twitter sake
and if they want to ban me too in order
to protect this predator they want to
keep doing that then they can but until
that time comes I'm just going to
continue with what I'm doing
all right I think we'll leave it there
thanks everybody for watching Godspeed
if you prefer facts over feelings if you
aren't offended by the brutal truth if
you can still laugh at the nuttiness
filling our national news cycle well
tune on into the ben shapiro show or
you'll get a whole lot of that and much
more we'll see you there